we're told to find the x and
y-intercepts for the graph of this
equation 2y plus 1/3 X is equal to 12
and just as a bit of a refresher the
x-intercept the x-intercept is the point
on the graph that intersects the x axis
so we're not above or below the x axis
so our Y value must be equal to 0 and by
the exact same argument the y intercept
the y intercept occurs when we're not to
the right or the left of the y-axis so
that's when X is equal to 0 so let's set
each of these values to 0 and then solve
for what the other one has to be at that
point so for the x intercept for the x
intercept when Y is equal to 0 let's
solve this so we get 2 times 0 plus 1/3
X is equal to 12 I just said Y is equal
to 0 right there right up at 0 for y
well 2 anything times 0 is just 0 so
you're just left with 1/3 X is equal to
12 to solve for x we can multiply covey
the dividing both sides by 1/3 or we can
multiply both sides by the reciprocal of
1/3 the reciprocal of 1/3 is 3 or you
can even think of it as 3 over 1 so
times 3 over 1 and so we're left with 3
times 1/3 that just cancels out so
you're left with X is equal to 12 times
3 or X is equal to 36 so when y is equal
to 0 X is 36 or the point 36 comma 0 is
on the graph of this equation and this
is also the x-intercept now let's do the
same thing for the y-intercept so let's
set X equal 0 so you get 2y plus 1/3
times 0 is equal to 12
once again anything times 0 is 0 so
that's 0 and you're just left with 2y is
equal to 12 divide both sides by 2 to
solve for y and you're left with Y is
equal to 12 over 2 is 6 so
y-intercept is when X is equal to 0 and
Y is equal to 6 so let's plot these two
points on a I'll just do a little
hand-drawn graph and make it clear what
the X and the y intercepts are so let me
draw that's my vertical axis and that is
my horizontal axis and we have the point
36 comma 0 so it might be way so this is
the origin right here that's the x-axis
that's the y-axis the point 36 comma 0
might be all the way over here so that's
the point 36 comma 0 and if that's 36
and the point 0 6 is going to be right
about 0 6 might be about right about
there so that's the point 0 6 and the
line will look like something like this
the line will look something like that
try my best to draw a straight line and
notice where the line intercepted or
intersected the y-axis that's the y
intercept X is 0 because we're not to
the right or the left of it where the
line intersected the x axis Y is 0
because we're not above or below it